new coronavirus relief spending is
bogged down again
in congress and that is very bad news
for people in danger of being evicted
the cdc has put a temporary hold on all
evictions
in an effort to protect public health
and prevent the spread of covet 19. but
that order expires on december 31st
if it is not extended 30 to 40 million
americans could lose their homes
nancy cordes spoke with some of them
nancy good morning to you
good morning i think of the millions of
americans who have lost their
jobs due to this pandemic and now 10
months
in renters owe an estimated 70
billion dollars in back rent and some of
them are being warned
that they could be tossed out of their
homes over the holidays
if congress doesn't act
renters visited a church on houston's
east side tuesday
hoping for legal advice on how to avoid
eviction
i'd be homeless with nobody to help
in houston alone more than 17 thousand
evictions have been initiated since the
pandemic began
300 thousand or more could be coming if
the federal moratorium on evictions
is allowed to expire it's just out of my
hands basically
that has david flores worried his
construction work has dried up
and his wife's unemployment has run out
whatever little income we do come across
you know we have to separate it between
whatever bills that we are able to pay
or whatever little gas we're able to put
in the vehicle
it's just hard as cries for rent relief
grow
louder experts say eviction isn't just
an economic issue
one recent study found that more than
400 thousand coronavirus cases
and 10 thousand deaths were linked to
the expiration of various
state eviction protections over the
summer housing is health care
diane yantel leads the national
low-income housing coalition i think
it's very clear what the consequences
will be
if congress does not provide an extended
eviction moratorium and substantial
rental assistance
and that is a tsunami of evictions she's
pushing for congress to add 100 billion
dollars in rental assistance
to any covid relief deal what has this
eviction moratorium done
to landlords because they're not all fat
cats a lot of them rely on
this rental income for their own
families yeah that's absolutely right
especially the small landlords and
that's why emergency rental assistance
is so
essential it helps the renters pay the
rent and it helps the landlords pay the
bills
without it even a federal moratorium
can't prevent
all evictions the cdc order actually
only
stops eviction cases that are based on
non-payment of rent
so what that means is if there are other
breaches of the lease
the landlord can potentially proceed
houston lawyer jonah treble represents
dozens of renters through lone star
legal aid she's bracing for a flood of
evictions if the protections
do expire in three weeks all the cases
from the last four months are going to
come back to life
instantly if there was previously a
constable on the way to the home to
remove the tenant family those will pick
right back up where they left off
i have no money for rent chris levy
racked up multiple warnings from his
landlord in orlando
but just managed to pay off thousands in
back rent with help
from a national charity which gave him a
few months of breathing room
i have a seven-year-old daughter it's
life or death for me really
rental assistance funding is tied up in
this larger fight over a covid relief
package and when i asked speaker pelosi
yesterday about this she said she wanted
to extend the eviction moratorium
but she couldn't guarantee it at this
point anthony so many people in
desperate need of help nancy thank you